So what are some reasons you might
want to consider investment for
your business?
Let's look at what investing is then
go over some of the benefits and
downsides of choosing this option for
your startup.
First, what is investing?
Investing is the process of
putting money into something
in hope of financial or material gain.
So, when you're looking for
investors you'll be dealing with people
who want to give you money upfront
in exchange for later returns
on this initial investment.
The motivations of each individual
investor may vary, but keeping their
incentives in mind will help you
better understand the benefits and
downsides of dealing with investors.
So, why might you consider
working with these investors?
Let's overview three of them,
funding, contacts, and motivation.
First, funding.
An obvious benefit of dealing with
investors is that they have money
available to help you
jumpstart your business.
With investment,
you can expand more quickly and
allocate some of the risk
to your investors.
Next, contacts and advice.
Many investors have groups of other
investors, entrepreneurs, and
advisors they associate with.
You can use their contacts
to seek more funding.
It's in an investor's best interest to
help you get the resources you need and
the right investor will
be able to provide them.
And finally, motivation.
An investment is in some
ways like a marriage.
If you marry the wrong person,
working with them will be miserable, and
they may end up sinking the business.
But finding the right investor
means both monetary investment and
personal investment.
They'll be there through many
of the obstacles you face and
will give a second set of eyes on
what you're spending your money on.
If having someone else around helps
provide the motivation you need
then an investor can be
a great asset to your company.
So, those are some of the benefits
of working with investors, but
what are some of the downsides?
Let's look at three, rate of return,
communication, and control.
First, rate of return.
Above all else, investors are trying
to make money, and they expect a higher
rate of return than what traditional
investments can provide.
What is important to
an investor is how your plan
ends up with more money
in their pockets.
It can be difficult to balance this
pressure from investors with your
original vision.
Because of this you'll end up needing
to communicate your decisions with
investors.
You'll spend more time
explaining your ideas and
dealing with the political
aspects of your company.
And finally, control.
Sometimes the decisions you
make won't be well accepted and
could even scare away
potential investors.
Even though it is your company,
once an investor is involved,
you've given up some of the control
you had over the direction you take.
Does reaching out to an investor
seem like a good option to you?
Take some time to consider
each of the benefits and
downsides of working with investors for
your startup.